[Music]
well due to the pandemic in our state
being hit
so hard with the entertainment and
hospitality industries
our state's unemployment rate is at 12
percent
and that's almost double the national
average so metro wants to take some of
the burden off
for these struggling families kirsten
joyce joining us now with more on the
details of what they're trying to do
denise metro will be handing out
thousands of these meals ahead of the
thanksgiving holiday to help southern
nevadans
metro of course does this every year but
this year they increased the number of
turkeys from 2000 to 3000
because of the huge demand this year
with all the challenges presented by the
virus
people in economic need foreclosures and
people being
pushed out of their residences this is a
time we'll be able to come together
and actually really come together as a
community
dozens of officers have their vehicles
lined up ready to load with the turkeys
and other items
once loaded they drove to each of their
commands to surprise individuals
families
shelters churches and other agencies who
support nevadans in need
more than 300 thousand people are
struggling with hunger in our state and
about 40 percent of that number
children due to covet as we said more
people this year are asking for help for
the very
first time so this is all made possible
through a collaboration by the lvmpd
foundation
anthem blue cross blue shield nevada
medicaid and of course three square
brian
kirsten thank you